[Musique]
alexander
là
non
[Musique]
mais
prévenu aux vieux problème
et non fait
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
savez vous comment écrire un message
secret aux 20e siècle c'était le grand
jeu des espions je vais vous montrer
pour écrire un message secret il vous
faut pas s'y tromper un verre un pinceau
et une feuille vous écrivez votre
message secret avec le jus de citron
et voilà mon message secret bien se
créer un maintenant vous laissez sécher
pour le lire il faut une bougie et la
présence d'un adulte car on joue pas
avec le feu au contact de la chaleur les
sucres contenus dans le jus de citron
car analyse et colore le papier ce qui
permet de lire le message
et voilà chers epicure yeux ça vous a
donné envie d'essayer montré dans vos
messages
non
movies
le cas d'un road movie
de la cia
un million
tu as lu un million d'abonnés sur tik
tok qu'elles ont dit
merci